the evolutionary argument that we are or
that men are ejaculating because they're
making room for better quality sperm
cells fresher sperm cells and getting
rid of the old does have a lot of
currency I think but it also poses a bit
of a problem from an adaptive
perspective across species because we do
seem to be the most masturbatory species
of them all
we masturbate much more than other
animals that's not to say the other
animals don't you know play with
themselves or dogs don't you know mount
people's legs but we seem to be unique
in the sense of using our manual
appendages to actually arrive at orgasm
so masturbation to completion seems to
be the key here in terms of a possible
unique aspect of human sexual behavior
what I argue in the book is that this is
the reason this is unique to human
beings is because we have a fairly
advanced social cognitive system that
allows us to basically playback scenes
in our heads like a dirty movie theater
where you know we're going through
things that we experienced you know in
the course of our daily lives or
pornographic images that we saw on the
internet or something like that I really
don't think there's anything too
outrageous in terms of what you can
concoct in your head for the purposes of
masturbation at least that is something
that maybe I don't know if we should
take pride in that but it is something
that does seem to be special to to human
beings not only are we visualizing these
erotic scenes when we're masturbating
but we also use our imagination in this
way when we're you know actually having
sex with other people
especially people that were not
particularly attracted to or not as
aroused by them as we would like to be
oftentimes we introduced a whole roster
of other players in our heads as we're
having sex with that person just to
bring us to orgasm lots of people have
sex without the lights on it's not that
hard to do really but it's certainly
something that most people acknowledge
doing at least at some point in their
lives especially the longer you get into
a marriage the sort of romantic erotic
fatigue inevitably occurs we don't
oftentimes share that with the partner
in terms of what we're imagining in our
heads as we're having sex
but chances are they're probably doing
the same thing with us so I don't think
that they should you know we should
really take it too personally a lot of
people who have paraphilia is use this
type of mechanism as well to somehow
escape the the very limited type of
stimulus or arousal erotic target that
attracts them if they're only attracted
to horses for example well maybe they
can be in a successful marriage if
they're thinking about horses that
they're having sex with their wives so
the wife wouldn't really want to hear
that but from an evolutionary
perspective at least can get them to
obtain an orgasm and to perpetuate their
genes